hey guys it is the fourth of September
my name is Jess Miguel and you're tuned
into gamespot news today's edition may
make you want to buy a new generation
console you've been warned destiny has
another ps4 exclusive content trailer up
and this time it involves a corpse
strike mission the mission is called
dust palace it's set on Mars and
designed for players who've reached
level 18 you'll be shooting at a race
called the Cabal who in turn will be
shooting back at you the Cabal enemies
range from totally built Centurions to
the Scion playa a nimble enemy with
advanced AI this mission is exclusive to
the ps4 version of destiny only until
fall of next year check out the full
three minutes of trailer on site for a
walkthrough of the level and a heavy
dose of colorful commentary next up that
game with the Romans and the warring
rice that a room is coming to PC in
October an updated steam product page
indicates that the game is out
officially on October 10 and we get a
glimpse of the minimum system
requirements which is always a hot topic
to bring up on the news developer Crytek
haven't confirmed either of those things
the requirements seem to be relatively
high but you can check out the nitty
gritty for yourself in our story on site
the pc version is set to support 4k
resolution and feature all of the rise
deal see that's been released to date if
you haven't been keeping up to date with
your rise DLC of late I can tell you
that it's a whole mess of stuff next up
Microsoft want to give you a free game
if you buy an xbox one in the States
next week if you've been holding out and
had your eye on Microsoft's box now is
probably a good time to take the plunge
between September 7 and sep tember 13 if
you purchase their console from any
participating retailers which is most of
the big ones you'll be able to grab
yourself any Xbox one game you want to
go with it totally free as far as the
game selection is concerned Microsoft to
say the sky's the limit that is right up
until pre-order games so pre-order games
at the limit what is fancy though is
that the deal works for Xbox one console
bundles so you can get a bundle that
includes a game and
get another game on top of that for free
just not a preorder one because that's
the limit as for your question of the
day let me know if you've yet to buy a
new generation console as why you've
decided to hold up those are all the
things I wanted to tell you about today
do remember that tomorrow is top five
time where I bring you five of the very
best gaming stories of the whole week so
I hope to catch you then